this week nine Labour MPs left the party
and it's fair to say there's no shortage
of independent-minded backbenchers still
they're trying to fight from within I'm
joined by one of them as Stella Creasy
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning first of all what
is your reaction to the news that we've
seen this week several labor and
peaceful it could no longer stay in the
Ponte I'm gutted and I have called for
the party from the grassroots to the
leadership to not lash out right now but
to learn from what this tells us about
the culture of our party and the
challenges that we face we've lost a
good colleague of mine in Luciana Berger
sorry I think we I have to say I'm
deeply concerned by the reports of what
happened on Friday night in my colleague
Louise Ullman's constituency these are
both proud people from the Jewish faith
who are loose and was a Labour MP Lucy
Lewis still is who have faced
unacceptable bullying and harassment
because they are Jewish from members of
our own party if that isn't a moment for
us as a party to look at ourselves and
ask what is going wrong and what we must
do to put it right I don't know what is
I mean Barry garden he was on the
program earlier we're saying that some
of the response hasn't been quick enough
but labour is getting on top of it now I
mean do you believe that's right so I
think there's two things one there are
the cases that have come forward it is
troubling to me that we found time to
look at whether or not to let Derek
bahattin back into the labour party but
yet we know that there are many many
cases about anti-semitism outstanding I
know of cases but there's also something
here about the culture of the labour
party and not waiting till cases come
forward if people are concerned about
high Semitism at a party we have a proud
affiliate called the Jewish labor
movement and right now they're talking
about possibly not being part of our
move what now affiliation means sonic to
me that's why I'm a socialist and I feel
very strongly that we've got to stand
with the Jewish labor movement the
Jewish labor movement were offering
training to every constituency Labour
Party about what anti-semitism is
because one of the things that's
troubled me over the last week is I've
had a number of people writing and
saying to me well I haven't seen any
anti-semitism that Jeremy Corbyn says
rightly we've got a problem with
anti-semitism
John McDonnell says rightly we've got a
problem so it's our membership that
actually needs to also have a
conversation about what anti-semitism is
and I'd like to see is one of the things
coming out of this horrific week a
commitment not only to stand by the
Jewish labour moon but actually take
practical action what do I mean by that
firstly I mean writing to every
constituency in this country from the
lay party to tell them that the Jewish
labor movement how people can join how
they can affiliate my local party's
affiliated to them and we're proud to
have them in our movement but also
offering to support the training that
they do so that we're not just waiting
for these cases to come forward we can
finally put to bed the idea that the
Labour Party is institution and Semitic
by not just dealing with the complaints
but also dealing with the concerns but
do you think the party is
institutionally and I can understand why
people are concerned because even after
these complaints have come forward I'm
sad to see that we did select three
people who were Holocaust deniers to be
labour candidates a local government
level now the vast majority of labour
members I've been proud to be in this
party for 26 years and they are proud
anti-racist and campaigners so actually
what we should want to do is get out
there have that training be proud about
the fact we're talking about these
issues in the labour movement not see it
as a threat but see it as part of our
DNA if you feel so strongly about this
why you still a member of the party I've
been a member of a party for 26 years I
don't have blind loyalty to the labour
movement I have ideological loyalty on a
socialist I want a radically different
progressive country and I want to fight
for it and I want to work with everybody
in the labour movement to do that so
this is part of what I stand for but
that doesn't mean that my loyalty is
silent to this party it means that I
stand up and I speak up and it's a
difficult question for all of us and
only I listened to sneak Khan when he
says actually we are all guardians of
the Labour values that we care about
that brought us into this party that
frankly bring us here on a Sunday
morning championing what Labour can do
for this country we all have a duty to
make us the best of the labour movement
and that's also a local level nationally
well that's why I think that training
and that commitment to actually having
that conversation about what
anti-semitism is you know when I hear
people say this is about criticism in
Israel and yet with the same breath
holding all Jews accountable for what
happens from the Israeli government I
know we've got a job of work to do when
sadly members in my own local party
write free Palestine in response to the
concerns about anti-semitism
from other Labour MPs on my Facebook
page I know we have a job of work to do
and yes I have heard anti-semitism
expressed in the Labor Party that is why
I'm determined to stand up for the
reputation of the vast majority of
members who know it's wrong and know now
we need to show that we're gonna do
something about it Emily Phil Murray the
Italian foreign secretary said she'd
rather die than lead the labour party is
that how you feel I am passionate about
socialism I'm passionate about what it
can do for this country as I said I'm
not silent therefore about when I see
challenges within the labor movement and
within society at 26 years of being a
Labour Party member I've never entirely
agreed with any Labour leader and I've
always fought for labour governments
because I think we have a case to make
to the British public I understand right
now while people are asking us questions
about anti-semitism and I think there
are things that we can do to right rule
out leaving the Labour Party yes I've
been a Labour Party member I've been
very clear I'm not going anywhere I'm
standing with the Jewish labor movement
I'm standing with my colleagues like
Ruth Smith but I'm also here today to
say the reports we've heard about what's
happened to people like Louise almond
are completely unacceptable and I hope
on Monday when the PLP reconvenes again
we're going to hear about concrete
actions like some of the things I've
just suggested that will help us deal
with this problem and break this now it
really struck me this week that
two-thirds of the independent group of
women and I just wonder if you think
that perhaps with a sort of toxic nature
of some of our politics online do you
think that women in particular get a bit
of a raw deal
I think women can't win one of the
things I'm on a mission to do is to end
the concept of difficult women because I
always say I'm not difficult I'm just
different I bring a different set of
experiences a different set of ideas to
the table but it is absolutely true that
we've seen women in particular targeted
and I am horrified as well by what I've
seen happened to my colleague Diana Baur
who's also one of my next-door neighbour
MPs undoubtedly misogyny is intertwined
in this indeed there was a conference
recently about misogyny and
anti-semitism and how those have been
intertwined as well there is clearly
something going wrong with our politics
across the piece when it's particularly
voices that perhaps haven't been heard
before or trying to be silenced what I
would say to everybody is this isn't
just a problem for Jewish people to sort
out or for women to sort out all of us
miss out when our politics is full of
and rather than dancers and it means we
don't hear the contribution some of
those new ideas can come from as a
result well let's talk about that anger
in our politics it feels like it's a
really aggressive place one I'm sorry I
got really cross the other night on your
Twitter feed I'm really sorry
no that's fun we're allowed to be angry
sometimes but it just feels that people
aggressive should we say at other times
and one of the quotes that stood out to
me this week was from the chair of Gavin
shook his constituency Labour Party we
have a little look now he of course
there's one of the people who left the
Labour Party the chair said we look
forward to him calling a by-election
where he will be annihilated and
consigned to the dustbin of history
where he belongs now clearly emotions
running high it's a lot of anger
directed towards these MPs who many in
the labor movement feel and making a
concerted government more likely what do
you make by the time the debate so when
I see things like this I think about the
brilliant words of Rhys Meath today look
this week rather in Parliament and she
said one of the reasons that she was
standing up and fighting with the laymen
wasn't actually about MPs it was about
every young campaign at every activist
who hasn't yet got involved in the
labour party hasn't yet contributed to
or doing hasn't yet helped us fight for
a Labour government who sees and hears
things like that and says actually this
isn't for me we all have a
responsibility to change that culture we
all have a responsibility that it's
important to have a robust debate
I've lost lots of arguments within the
labour party I'll continue to make
arguments I'm in a different place and a
lot of people say for example on brexit
I would like to see us have that second
referendum but those are policy
arguments this is about our culture and
how we speak to each other and what we
show the elektra a Labour Party in the
labour movement is about we've got to be
the best of ourselves and the best
fossils is not digging down other people
it's standing up for what we believe in
and being passionate about the positive
difference it will make for our country
it's Jeremy Corbyn done enough
I think it's right that people are
asking Jeremy to be part of it sometimes
I think this goes back to first
principles just saying first and clearly
that every Jewish member of our labour
movement should feel proud to be part of
the labour movement and if they don't
it's a problem for all of us that every
woman's voice should be welcomed in the
labels of hazard so I'd like to see
Jeremy just start with some of those
first principles I take my heart to him
he's fighting really hard to get us a
Labour government but I think some
he hasn't yet said those first
principles just been clear a bit like
Essex University this week didn't simply
say that every Jewish student should
feel welcome on campus and if they
didn't it was a problem for them and
then we see 200 people voting against
the existence of a Jewish society
sometimes it's just important to state
what you believe is important and that's
what I think Jeremy's got to do first
and foremost well I've got you I'm
interested to get your thoughts on a
very different story that's during the
news this week actually Matt begum you
represent more than so very diverse
community and I just wonder what you
think should happen to shimu bacon who
of course is the baton of green school
girl who left the UK when she was a
teenager to join Islamic state she's
just giving back yes so I had to say
Sophie I'm slightly concerned that
you've pointed out I represent a diverse
community because actually my concern
about the shamina beacon case is nothing
to do with the diversity of my community
it's a worry I have to see a Home
Secretary seeking essentially to make
policy on the hoof without proper
scrutiny in Parliament I have no
sympathy for sure Meena Begum but I
absolutely am concerned to see
somebody's citizenship being stripped
away and last night we started seeing
the comment pieces suggesting that she
wasn't really British even though she
was born here this is a very worrying
trend we've seen the rise of the
far-right in this country we've seen the
rise of that kind of divisive hateful
rhetoric and actually it's not about
people in Walthamstow it's about the
morality of this country . it is by
these difficult cases and the tests that
they set us or whether we stand up for
our principles that you should know us
and so what do you think should happen
oh i think she should come back here and
face the full force of the law i have no
sympathy for her i'm concerned she might
know about other issues of terrorism
that she needs to be properly
interrogated about but i certainly think
that the idea that stripping her
citizenship and making it makes the
problem go away it doesn't and I'm
deeply deeply worried by a Home
Secretary who doesn't stand up for the
importance of the rule of law and due
process because if you can do it to one
person you can do it to other people
okay Stella crazy thank you very much